[Music]
for the better part of two decades
school improvement has been focused on
narrowing achievement gaps by boosting
the performance of low achieving
students in reading and math this
mission has undeniable merit but it also
carries real costs one cost is a lack of
attention to those students who are
hungry for learning that stretches
beyond the corners of state academic
standards another is that teachers feel
so obliged to focus on gap closing
instructions that they feel far less
free to devote time and energy
supporting advanced learning when
students seek to master advanced math
research historical essays or plunge
into biochemistry that should be
celebrated not merely tolerated as
William Fitzhugh the founder of the
world's only Journal for academic
research papers by high school students
has pointedly put it we could at least
encourage two crazy ones
so for 2019 here's a healthy resolution
for school improvement let's at least
make sure we're also encouraging the
passion at once how do you think schools
can better support passionate students
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI